hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video meine damen und herren ihr seht
schon wir befinden uns auf einem auf
einem der letzten plätze
das hier ist kein scheiß wird die
gescheitert
ich bin ganz gut verteilt von anderen
youtube angeschaut mal gesehen und
hayley befindet sich jetzt in
irgendwelchen krassen kunstrasen allen
die haben kraftsport landesliga die
neben den westen fußballplatz die wir
beiden breit im umfeld von köln gewinnen
konnten und reagieren köln im umkreis
der welt ja und wir machen ja challenge
mit drei kellerei megatrend meine damen
und herren im plattensee den schon da
hinten ein tor eingeblendet und auf
jeden fall werden wir gleich genau von
schiedsrichtern mit den ball hinlegen
und ich werde auch dadurch damit max auf
das tor schießen
das tor wird übrigens diese drei
baumstämme dort und werte er die latte
trifft gewinnt diese challenge
[Musik]
meine damen
er war komplett schaltet die anlage
[Gelächter]
challenge verloren doch wie kommen
stellen ist natürlich die erste
challenge ist grandios gewonnen habe bei
der zwei meter große da hinten sondern
dieses kleine ford hier und die sich
gerade drei verschiedenen ländern auf
jeden fall werden wir jetzt gleich von
jeder position jeder ein schuss haben
und versuchen das zweite tor von dort
treffen
[Applaus]
übrigens gab es einen punkt von dieser
position nach vorne zwei punkte von
diesem beutel da hinten und die drei
punkte von der flasche da oben als wir
gehen jetzt erst mal über eine
schiedsrichter markierung
[Musik]
ich bin trotzdem 30
[Applaus]
spiel punkten geklettert
[Musik]
die dritte zehe und meine damen und
herren wir sehen hier schon wieder weg
von hinten wie kommerzielle müssten
beschreiben alle davon hören sie sehen
schon dort hinten wieder unser brachial
geniale tor eingeblendet maxit jetzt in
dieses tor wandern max im tor da hinten
und ich werde jetzt noch elf metern man
elfmeterschießen immer soll ich auf
elfmeter von schiedsrichter markierung
braucht davor schützen und werden von
zwei begriff jeder schied abwechselnd
gewinnt dieses komplette video
[Musik]
[Applaus]
freunde waren waren gute video verkennen
videos von uns nicht so gut aber dieses
video können man schon für den rap video
preislich video youtube des jahres
einreichen werde bitte macht ist doch
mit dem wartet ihr vom video haltet ihr
vom video ihr könnt jetzt hier meinen
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
job checken jetzt wenn ich jetzt für
andere videos zeichnen sie auch die
glocken klingen da kommt die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]